let's get into audience questions
there's some really good topics this
week first one is from gila gila says
hey David how do you explain the
horribly low approval rating for
Congress and the very high reelection
rate for Congress yeah that's a good
question you would think that if
Congress if congressional approval is so
low that you would see a correspondingly
low reelection rate for members of
Congress but that's not actually the
case so I think there's two different
phenomena at play here number one is
this idea that while big picture people
say Congress is a disaster I don't
approve of the job they're doing a lot
of people simultaneously believe that
their elected officials their member of
Congress is not part of the problem or
is not that bad right so you will very
often see in other words to get an 11%
congressional approval you would imagine
that that would be sort of the average
or mean of all congressional approvals
and that thus there would be people that
are well below 11% that would get us to
that 11 percent but what it turns out is
that even though as an institution
people don't approve of Congress they
tend to approve of their own elected
officials to a much higher degree
because they apparently believe that
it's all of the other elected officials
that are the problem so that's number
one and that's sort of a basic
behavioral economics phenomena that has
been discussed a lot that's number one
number two is that the power of
incumbency allows you to raise money and
that when you have more money you're way
more likely to win so even if your
approval rating isn't that high because
you're an elected official you're going
to get contributions not only from
individuals but also from from lobbying
groups corporations etc and we know that
when you have more money you're more
likely to win so that's why and it's a
very reasonable question it's a similar
question to wait a second if our elected
officials represent us why is it that
even though most people want net
neutrality they could only get just
around half of all senators to support
it because most of their constituents
support net neutrality why wouldn't
there be more senators supporting it
it's a similar sort of thing where the
numbers don't match up with each other
and you would think if if people think
Congress is so horrible there should be
more incumbents Lewis
but it's just not the way the system is
built in fact I would argue the system
by design is one in order to consolidate
and maintain power where even with low
approval as a legislative body
individual members of Congress still
have a very good shot at being reelected
they want that in order to maintain
their power in the status quo yeah and
we also just live in a very diverse
country - I mean if you asked me if I
approve of my liberal congressman or
senator from you know Massachusetts from
Boston or Cambridge wherever I would
probably say yes okay but then if you
ask me if I approve of some senator or
congressman from Utah I would say no and
the people living there would say the
exact opposite well yeah and I think
that's part of the entire yeah I don't
agree with what agree with what the body
is doing but my specific elected
official just isn't a part of the
problem it's everybody else that's a
part of the play I like if we were in
Europe we would be consisted of maybe
like 10 countries right we're just that
diverse yes I've said this before when I
have traveled to northern Florida not
Miami Beach but northern Florida or I
was recently in rural Miami or when I've
been to California or other parts of the
country really all we have in common is
that we've decided the name of the
country is the United States of America
and ostensibly we have the same
president at all time not extensively we
have the same president although not
everybody ever recognizes that president
as their president in the same way but
really these very well could be
different countries and the cultural
differences between regions of the
United States are certainly bigger or at
least as big as the cultural differences
that exist between some of the smaller
European countries for sure but I do
think there are solutions here and you
laid out some of them and it has a lot
to do with campaign finance reform and
gerrymandering to solving that